Welcome friends, whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home.
It's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Dave Mowry.
Dave is a comic telling his story of
living with severe mental
illness one joke at a time. He also
teaches stand-up comedy to folks with
a mental illness, helping them find humor
in their dark days and lost years.
Dave, welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Thank you, Danny. Great to be here.
This is awesome. Now, before we get
started,
I also wanted to point out that you are
the bestselling author of the
OMG That's Me Mental Health Books.
You're a blogger of over 1 million reads
and you like to say you're comic
who shatters stigma one joke at a time.
Exactly, exactly.
That is,
wow, that's so to dig into.
Yeah, yeah.
Where would you like to start?
I mean, your experience with bipolar and
what that meant to you,
and we'll just weave back and forth and
just have a good conversation.
Yeah, that's great. think starting,
you know, with the bipolar, I was a
successful businessman.
I had it all. It seemed like happy family,
know, nice house, kids. Everything was
great.
Then in 1994, I had a psychotic break
and fell into a deep,
deep, deep depression. couldn't function.
I couldn't function socially. couldn't do
anything business.
I couldn't function.
And we lost everything. ~ We lost our
house.
We were homeless for 18 months with the
kids.
~ And that started my 14 lost years and
dark days
of not being able to function socially,
~ not being able to sometimes get out of
bed.
I couldn't go to the mailbox in case I saw
a neighbor and they'd look at
my eyes and see just.
see the illness, the sadness,
the loss, the sense of dread, the
overwhelming sense of dread.
And so I'd go to the mailbox at night so I
wouldn't see anybody.
If I heard a song on the radio,
it would trigger an experience,
a thought, and I'd have a panic attack.
It was bad. It was terribly bad.
I spent time in the hospital. But those
are my last years.
~
Yeah, I mean I could tell you stories
about the dark days and
the overwhelming sense of depression and
the impacts,
but you know we don't need to go to all
those dark places unless you'd like
to go to some of them.
Well, I think you have an excellent point.
Maybe not going to all of those dark
places,
but I'm listening to you from the
perspective of my listeners and viewers.
And in case
Mm.
there's someone out there who happens to
be sliding down into what may
be some lost years for them, or maybe
they're in a lost year right now
and they just happen to be listening to
this podcast,
what I would be interested in you
potentially sharing are some
some
experiences, maybe pick two or three that
were more poignant for
you that would explain to people that
maybe have never experienced something
like
this. Somebody that's listening,
they might have a friend or a relative who
is going through this,
but they don't understand the practicality
of what someone actually feels,
what was an experience, and if you could
share it in a way that they
can understand if you were going through
this,
what it's actually like.
The depths of depression are almost
indescribable.
think there's situational depression
and clinical depression in my mind and the
clinical depression is awful.
You go to these deep, deep dark places
with constant negative
thoughts.
If I was able to get out of the bed in the
morning and make it to the couch,
was everything I could do just to sit and
just to be.
just to hold it together, just to be,
I prayed and prayed and prayed for peace
of mind.
~ I couldn't shower.
~ I couldn't shower. People commented,
I wrote a blog post about T.D.
Presta's shower and the overwhelming
response was,
me too, me too, you tell my story.
And ~ if I did make it to a social
function,
I'd...
stand against the wall and try to blend
into the wall and pray that nobody came
up to talk to me. And if somebody did come
up to talk to me,
I'd answer in one word, one syllable words
and try to be as boring
as possible so they'd go away.
The panic attacks were overwhelming.
If somebody did come to talk to me,
if there was any added stress or anxiety
at all,
I'd start to sweat and have a panic
attack.
And I'd have to...
It was everything I could do just not to
just take off and run away,
but I escaped as soon as I could.
And it would take days to recover.
I think, you know, for folks who are going
through this to understand it,
there is,
I mean, I was in the darkest, deepest
places,
and there is hope.
You know, you can come out the other side.
I never resigned myself.
to that that was the way it was always
going to be.
~ I did accept the fact that I had bipolar
disorder and severe anxiety,
~ but I just kept trying
Mm-hmm.
and kept trying, kept failing.
I don't know if that's the right word,
but I'd crash and burn and then three
months later I'd try again.
But if you're listening, you've got a
family member,
yeah, those are some of the experiences.
And I could go on and on.
I remember someone telling me one time
that for them,
getting out of the bed, just trying to get
out of the bed in the morning,
we're not even talking about taking a
shower,
just getting out of the bed. They said,
Dana, trying to do that felt like I was
trying
to pull the leviathan from the ocean
depths.
The energy that it took to just get out of
the bed.
was so much more than they had.
Like they were being asked to do something
that was so much more than they
had the energy to do. And I thought,
well, that was, I never forgot that
description.
Yeah, yeah, and that's exactly right.
You're laying there. I would lay there
just trying to hold it together,
just again, just trying to hold it
together,
just trying to be in getting out of bed to
do anything was overwhelming.
And I'd sleep in my clothes.
It was too much to take off my clothes at
night to go to bed.
It was too much if I did get out of bed.
It was too much to get dressed again.
So I slept in my clothes for months and
months and months.
It was just too much to take off my
clothes and to put them back on.
Okay. You said something a few moments ago
that sparked a memory of mine.
I remember having a conversation with
someone one time and she said that
she was terrified that she was never going
to get better because there was no,
she had no proof, she had no evidence that
this horrible darkness,
this horrible weight
was ever going to go away. And for her,
that was almost worse than the current
situation was this terror that
she was always going to be stuck there.
That if somebody could tell her,
no, you're not going to be stuck there,
she could like hold onto it like to a life
raft in the middle of a tsunami.
But she didn't have that.
And so that she was just terrified that
she was going to stay just like that
for the rest of her life.
Exactly. I felt the same way when you're
in that deep dark hole
and you look up,
you don't see a light. You don't see an
end.
I didn't see an end. I hope for an end.
I tried. Like I said, I tried and tried
again and tried again.
And it's important,
I think, what I share with people is don't
get stuck.
~
When we're feeling that way and that
there's no hope and no end in sight,
just do something small. If it's getting
out of bed and going downstairs and
sitting on the couch,
that's an accomplishment. But if you're in
that state,
sit in a different spot on the couch.
Sit in a different chair.
If you're taking medicine, I'd take them
in order,
left to right, ~ and then sometimes I'd
take them right to left.
And each one of those little things was me
not getting stuck,
me finding a little hope that there was
the possibility that I'd come out of this.
Those are great. I love those ideas.
Just really small bites and really
readjusting the expectation,
your self-expectation.
Yeah.
It's got to be readjusted during that
period of time.
Yeah, definitely.
So,
Dave, you mentioned your family,
and I'm kind of wondering, and I'm
listening again
Hmm.
from the point of my listeners,
and sometimes it's hard for family members
to understand what's going
on, and they certainly have a right to
their own frustrations
and aggravations and confusion and these
types of things that people
are going to experience during something
like this.
What pieces of...
advice or words of encouragement or ~
support or inspiration or whatever that
you could give family members.
If there's a family member listening and
they have someone who's going through this
and they don't know what to do,
they don't know what it feels like,
they don't know when it's going to end,
they're experiencing as a family like you
so explained so well earlier about losing
your job, being homeless. mean,
there are definite consequences to going
through something like this.
What are some practical pieces of wisdom
that you could share with some family
members that might be listening?
I think first is that it's not a moral
failing.
It's ~ not a moral failing.
It's ~ a medical condition.
It's an imbalance
of the brain, a chemical imbalance of the
brain.
It's happening. So the person going
through it can't...
can't do anything about it at that point.
They're just trying to exist. as a family
member,
accepting the fact that it's not a
personal failing
and realizing that the person,
your spouse, is not lazy and that they're
doing
the best they can because truly they are.
And going through this and coming out the
other side is
one of the hardest things to do.
People with depression or bipolar
disorder,
you know, are the bravest people,
are the most courageous, the strongest to
be in this place and to get through it.
So I think acceptance, my wife accepted
the fact and didn't...
didn't ~ get angry with me for not getting
out of bed or just being able to sit on
the couch.
She just, she just, and she sat with me
and she accepted it.
And she's truly the hero of my story.
Without her, ~ you know,
she stayed with me during these losses and
these dark days where someone else
wouldn't. And she held the family together
and spent
And when we were homeless, we lost,
we were hundreds of thousands of dollars
in debt.
She took over the financial situation and
when
I couldn't and you know,
she's truly the hero of my story.
If not for her, I'd be in an SRO in Old
Town here
in Portland on the street or eating at
soup kitchens.
mean, she got me treatment. She got me
help.
She got me...
She just advocated for me. Truly.
She sounds amazing.
Absolutely amazing. So I'm hearing you
describe all of this and it's resonating
with
stories I've heard in my office from my
patients.
And I'm thinking, okay, wow,
you went from experiencing this to comedy,
to
Hmm.
stand up comedy.
So you're gonna have to, Dave,
I know,
you're gonna have to take us on this
journey and help bring us along to this,
connect these dots here. How did you go
from what you're describing
to even contemplating the idea of stand-up
comedy?
Yeah, and who knew? I mean, how do you,
you don't chart this path. just,
you don't chart this path. So as we went
along and,
and, you know, I started to get better.
found NAMI, National Alliance on Mental
Illness,
and I found NAMI affiliate. And that was
really helpful because one
of the hardest parts for me was
pretending.
It was so hard to pretend to be okay in
times when I was in a social situation or
a
was with somebody. just pretended so,
it was so hard to pretend to be okay when
I wasn't okay.
And I knew people could see it in my eyes.
So,
I found NAMI through Heather, my wife,
and they brought a,
actually the county, and there's a little
notice in the newspaper,
there was a class starting, a comedy class
for,
comedy class for folks with a mental
illness.
And at my wife's urging, I went.
And the first time I just sat there and
they asked to tell
all your story. I told some of my story
and the teacher of the comic that
was teaching said, that's just sad.
And it was just sad. I mean, it was just
sad.
But by the second class, I was looking for
humor in my experiences.
And just starting to look for humor in my
experiences was transformational.
Whereas I'd be driving down the street or
listening to radio and hear
a song that triggered me and I'd go into a
panic attack because it reminded
me of a bad situation. After taking the
class,
being in the class and looking for humor,
when that song came on and started to
trigger me,
I'd say, okay, where can I find the humor
in that?
And it reframed everything.
And then it turned out I had the ability
to find humor,
write jokes, laugh out loud funny jokes,
and I helped other people write jokes and
find humor in their stories.
~ And then after the class ended,
we performed. It went great. And on stage,
I wasn't nervous because I was telling my
story one joke at a time.
It was completely honest, completely
honest.
And ~ I liked my jokes.
And the audience laughed and it was great.
But then the class wanted to keep going.
So I facilitated the class. And then next
thing I was teaching a class
and I was teaching classes. And I saw the
same transformation happening
in other people that happened to me.
It reframed everything.
It really kickstarted my recovery.
Really kickstarted my recovery.
That is amazing.
And the power of humor,
it's, yeah, I, and, you know,
I wrote a book about it. It's called
Healing with Humor,
and it's a story of six people that went
through the class and have
had this transformation. ~ It's inspiring,
it's funny, their jokes are in there.
~ you know, hopefully be able to share
that story,
those stories with other people living
with mental illness that relate
and they'll laugh.
and family members can understand too.
my gosh, I just love that journey.
I know, so stand-up comedy. I
know. And then pretty soon we sold out the
helium comedy club,
185 people in the helium comedy club.
yeah,
it wasn't long and I was a thing.
And I mean, God knows, who knew?
I mean, who knew I was funny?
I love the way,
you you say, and I love this phrase,
you say that you are a comic who shatters
stigma one joke
at a time. And I love this because people
who are struggling and they think they're
the only one or there's
a shame component to it because maybe they
like you said they've lost their
job or whatever and they feel badly
because of
what's going on with them and they see the
consequences kind of going
on the people around them, they don't want
to talk about it.
You know, they don't want people to know
about it.
They don't want to talk about it.
And so that stigma grows and becomes more
powerful.
The more, you know, I heard a phrase one
time,
we are as ~ sick as our secrets.
And so the more secrets we're keeping,
the more we're not talking about it.
We just get sicker and sicker.
And so I love the way you phrase this as
you are a comic who shatters stigma
one joke at a time, because it gives you
that platform to be funny,
to tell a joke about it. But the comics
are like the ultimate truth tellers,
are they not?
They are.
They're the ultimate truth tellers in a
very funny way where people
can receive it and they can hear it and
they can participate in it.
What
was your experience when you started being
honest about different experiences
and trying to shatter these stigmas?
What kind of feedback did you get and what
was your experience?
Well, first, when I was blogging,
know, blogging for bphope.com and I wrote
all my blog posts,
that was, I was completely open and honest
about that and I told some
of my stories and that helped me.
The response from people was overwhelming.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and the
most common response was OMG,
that's me telling my story. So many blog
posts or,
you know, three steps to whatever or
things you can do to,
you know.
solve this or help with that. Mine was
just,
I just told the stories like I told you
about going to the mailbox
or too depressed to shower and people
could relate to that and that's why
I got so many views and whatnot.
~
Comedy gave me an opportunity to be honest
and to share my experiences.
But it also, when you say to somebody,
what's the vision you have of people with
a mental illness performing stand-up
comedy? You know, it's like, ~ you know,
you've got this vision. I don't know,
everybody's got a different vision of it.
But people come to the shows, and here we
are,
and we live with serious mental illnesses.
And we get up there and we're confident
and capable and we laugh out loud funny.
And it changes people's perspective of ~
those of us with a mental illness.
They see us as being strong and funny and
capable instead of being weak
and vulnerable. ~ Yeah,
so that's part of shattering the stigma.
~
But you know, I didn't tell people.
was ashamed. I knew the stigma.
My wife did tell some people about my
bipolar disorder.
The kids used to come over to our house
and play.
And after she told them, she wouldn't let
the kids come over to our house
and play with our kids. ~ So I was like,
yeah, don't tell anybody. Don't tell
anybody.
But then I came out, so to speak,
and that was huge. That was huge.
One thing though is people sometimes when
they start talking about their mental
illness, they overshare.
Mm-hmm.
And they tell their whole story,
try to tell their whole story all at once
and people just back away,
back away, back away. But, you know,
we can talk about it in bits and pieces
and ~ it's really healing,
really healing.
Yeah,
that is and one of things that I heard you
describing ~ was I went through
a ~ speaking course one time and the
leader was saying,
know, share, be honest,
be vulnerable, share things that are in
your rear view mirror.
because sometimes when you're currently in
it,
like you said, you tend to overshare,
you're kind of like dumping on the person,
you're almost clamoring onto them like
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
they're your life raft instead of you
being someone else's life raft.
But when you've gone through something,
like you said, the walking to the mailbox
or learning how to like
go sit in different places on the couch,
you were sharing something that you had
been through that was in your rear view
mirror and you learned something helpful
and then you were sharing.
That's kind of the difference that I hear
you describing.
Yeah, I think so. I think so. In the rear
view mirror,
yes. And these things that were being
homeless,
losing everything, I was a failure.
I was a failure as a husband, a father.
I was a failure. And sharing about those
experiences
opened it up. And I don't feel that way
anymore.
~
You know what you said is exactly right
and you don't know what's going
to happen in the future.
Yeah, mental illness is something that you
talk about in bits and pieces
or to people that you're really close to.
I think for me, writing about it in my
blog post
was really helpful. It helped other
people.
I think writing about our past
experiences,
I help people write. And people want to
write their whole story,
start at the beginning, go to the end.
And I tell them, no, pick a spot.
Pick a story, pick an event, pick,
you know, and write about that.
Write 600 words, write 800 words.
And then they're writing about a
particular experience.
Brings it into the light.
Mm-hmm.
Helps them accept it and move on from that
experience.
Exactly. And we all love a good story.
So it helps them to become a storyteller,
zeroing
Yeah, yeah.
in on one particular story. As I'm
listening to you describe this,
I'm wondering the people that you were
teaching how to be a stand-up comic,
what did they struggle with the most?
If you were to reflect back on your
experiences with them and teaching them,
what do you feel like they
they
had the most trouble trying to overcome as
they're learning to present their mental
illness in a stand-up comedy fashion.
I think first of all, being open and
honest about their experiences.
Once they were open and honest about their
experiences,
we could find humor in it and create jokes
out of it.
But people would come and they'd sit and
they wouldn't talk.
So we started out,
I started out, and it was as much a
support group as a comedy group.
And the classes were in 10 weeks,
so we had time to do that.
And then there were some people that came
in and they were...
They'd come in and we'd, in the first part
of a joke called the setup is the truth,
the honesty, you know, the reality.
And then the second part is the punchline
that makes people laugh.
It's a surprise, it's a creative part.
And some people couldn't get to that
creative part.
They would, we'd come up with a punchline
and they'd say,
but that's not real. You know?
That didn't happen.
And so, you know, they were the hardest
ones to get past that,
but they'd get past it. But really,
during the class, as you're in there with
group of people,
and you're talking, and you're being
honest,
and you're developing relationships,
and we went everywhere. Everything was,
we talked about everything. Everything.
Everything. And so we went to all those
places,
the dark places, the hard places,
the funny places, the...
Everybody in most of the classes,
almost everybody had suicide ideation at
some point.
And we'd talk about suicide and they'd
talk about that suicide ideation.
We'd talk about, okay, if you're going to
kill yourself,
what are you going to do? Jump off a
bridge,
run into a tree, and pretty soon we're
laughing,
we're talking. so we were taking some of
the,
one of the most important jokes I tell is
a suicide joke.
And you know, suicide's not funny,
but it's gentle suicide joke.
And it's huge. It's helped so many people.
And my wife loves it. So I'd like to share
it with you now if it's OK.
Well, I'm hoping you were going to share
it as you can't say all that
I know, I know. After that.
and then not share.
So
I had my experience with suicide and
chemical suicide.
I went out into a park. a gun.
I sat on a park bench. I looked at the
river and the sun.
glinting up the river. And I didn't do it.
I didn't do it. ~ So I had that experience
with suicide.
But my suicide joke is ~ one time during
my dark days when things were really,
really bad, I decided to end it all.
So I went up into the bathroom and I took
a bunch of pills.
Afterwards, I called my wife for help.
She said there are more pills under the
sink.
Hahahaha
That is hysterical!
It
is. And talk about the breaking the taboo
or the
stigma and making it okay to talk about
it.
I had a fellow, I'm a peer support
specialist,
I work with folks, had a fellow who was
seriously suicidal and had a plan,
everything. His parents brought him in,
he was an adult, but he was morose,
walking slowly, monotone, flat-faced,
you know, no...
no glint in his eye. And we talked and we
were in,
talked together for about an hour.
I, at one point I told him that joke and
he laughed and his whole demeanor changed.
His whole demeanor changed.
wow.
He said it's the first time he'd laughed
in years and it was a real belly laugh.
And it was, ~ and I had him come back the
next day and the next day
and we talked and we looked for humor in
his other experiences.
You know,
Wow.
and I'm comfortable in saying it saved his
life.
That is amazing. You know, I want to be
very encouraging to you and
to the listeners and the viewers that,
sometimes when we put ourselves out there
and do authentically what we feel
led to do, there's almost always going to
be critics.
There's almost always going to be the
naysayers,
the people that judge us, that criticize
and that type of thing.
I think it's important.
I mean, to obviously listen to the
feedback because there might
be something legitimate in the feedback
that can encourage us
to reevaluate what we're doing.
But at the end of the day, because I'm
listening to you describe the suicide
jokes,
and I can imagine, I would be shocked if
you did not have people along
the way who were battering you.
and probably calling you names and all
kinds of things for doing this.
And I'm so thankful that you stayed the
course and that you let them have their
opinion and you did not change your
authenticity.
What was your experience with that?
I honestly, ~ you know,
when I tell that joke, it takes a beat
before people.
come to, know, that it's okay to laugh.
Because it's a laugh out loud funny joke.
I mean, it's just a funny joke.
So it takes a second. It's a suicide joke
and they're kind of apprehensive
and I tell a joke and it takes just a beat
before they start laughing.
People with mental illness laugh,
they laugh the loudest and the hardest.
Family members laugh, they laugh loud and
hard.
I've only had one person come up to me
after a show and say,
you know, you probably shouldn't tell that
suicide joke because it's triggering.
And I talked to them and they were
somebody in the mental health field,
in helping profession. And they were
thinking that somebody else might be
triggered.
And I've never met that somebody else,
that person with the mental illness that
was triggered.
They think it's funny. They've had suicide
ideation.
They laughed out loud. You know,
it brings it out. And I think sometimes in
the helping profession,
people are out to save us, you know?
to save people with the mental illness,
they have to protect us. ~ sometimes they
treat
us like childlike in a sense that we can't
handle a word or a joke or whatever.
And it's exactly the opposite.
We're strong, we're capable, we're able,
we don't get triggered by a joke,
we don't get triggered by the word suicide
or the word crazy or the word,
you know, the game last night was insane.
~
You know, that stuff doesn't trigger us.
We don't need to be protected.
And I'd say, you for anybody in the health
and profession,
you know, we don't need to be saved.
You know, support us and all that,
but don't try to save us. We don't need
it.
I love that. I love it. I so as we're
wrapping up and I was I do this with
all of my guests as the queen of
boundaries,
I'm always interested in how boundaries
have impacted your
journey. Like, for example, what
boundaries protect your mental health
and your creative work now? Or you can
look back in on your your past journey
in ways that not having boundaries
possibly
worsened an experience or having
boundaries helped you in some kind of way.
Yeah, think not having boundaries was
during my mania,
the flights of fancy, the grandiosity.
I didn't have any boundaries. ~
The guilt I feel from the things I've done
came from mania.
~ The regrets I have from things I didn't
do or how I
did something come from the depression.
And so, you I didn't have the boundaries
with mania and,
you know, had problems and challenges.
Some boundaries, you know,
my sleep, I sleep.
I protect my sleep.
I've got to get enough sleep. If I don't
get enough sleep,
I'm not well. And that's common with
people with a mental health challenge.
~ If I can tell when I'm starting to get
depressed,
I still get depressed, but I don't go as
low.
Mania's not so high. don't go high.
With the medication, I'm just pretty
stable.
But I can feel myself sliding down into
that.
And I protect myself by saying it's OK.
You know? ~ I don't have to.
do this right now. I don't have to go to
this place right now.
It's okay to say, I'm not well.
And so those, you know, those are
important boundaries to me.
I love that. I'm hearing you say that you
give yourself permission to say no.
You know, someone might
Yeah.
be inviting you somewhere, somebody might
want you to do something
or go somewhere or participate in
something,
but you know that you're in a place
mentally where that's not a good choice
for you.
And so what I'm hearing you say is that
you're giving yourself permission
to say no in those instances
Yes.
to protect yourself.
Yes. And that's very important.
If I'm not well and I go...
It takes me days to recover. And I don't
contribute really anything to the event.
Got you.
If I'm there, I go to an event that I'm
not well,
I look for my chance to escape as quickly
as possible.
I go to the car, I lay down in the seat so
nobody can see me,
and I just try to hold it together.
And so, yeah, saying no, I don't go
through those experiences.
I did. I went through them over and over
and over.
You know, kept trying to be social.
I kept trying to do different things.
Finally, I learned that it's okay to say
no and to protect myself.
And, you know, know that,
you know, I am going to come out the other
side.
You know,
like I said, with the Phoenix.
And with going from successful businessman
to dark days in the last years
to peer support to blogging to stand-up
comedy
to being an author and writing books,
you know, I kept rising from the ashes.
And I kept trying, I kept trying,
even though I failed.
Well, you were definitely an inspiration.
Because it's failure, I think,
is inherent in life. And some people maybe
feel like they get dragged around that
more than others. And the getting up is
the power.
It's being that phoenix that's rising from
that pile of ash.
And I hear that in your story.
Dave, I know that there are numerous
people that are listening to this podcast,
watching this podcast.
that
want more access to you. So the website,
what I have on here is you want them to go
to basically Amazon and to look
for your book, the OMG That's Me!
Yeah, that's two things actually in
thinking about it.
For reaching me, I'll just tell you my
email.
It's davemowery2, the number 2 at
gmail.com.
I have a website, davemowery.com.
It's mostly focused on the books,
but there's a contact. And then,
omg, that's me. If anybody wants to know
that they're not alone.
It's an inexpensive book, it's an easy
read.
Get the book or the Kindle or the audio
book and you'll know you're not alone.
If you're a family member and you want to
know what it's truly like to live with
a mental illness, that's it. Those
experiences,
those dark days, those hard times,
those panic attacks, the barely being able
to get out of bed,
the not being able to shower, that's what
it's truly like to live with
a mental illness.
And then I've got ~ a new book that just
came out called Healing with Humor.
And it tells the story of the people that
took the class.
And it shows the resilience and the
strength.
It's inspirational. So if you want to go
to the books,
that's great. If you want to email me,
that's great. I answer all my emails.
So yeah.
~ Those are the ways to reach out to me
and find out more about me.
That is fantastic. Dave, you know,
I appreciate you being willing to spend
your precious time and your energy
and share with us your wisdom and your
experiences and being
so transparent with myself and the Phoenix
in Flame listeners and viewers.
Thank you very, very much.
You're welcome. I appreciate the
opportunity to be with you.
Now listeners and viewers, my goodness,
I know that you're thinking, wow,
I have a friend, I have a coworker,
I have a family member that absolutely
needs to hear what Dave has to say.
Take this podcast episode and copy and
paste it,
send it in a text, send it in the email,
put it on your favorite social media sites
so we can grow our Phoenix
In Flames community and let people know
you are not alone.
I hope your day is going great.
I hope the rest of it is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix in Flame.